like so many young girls nicole just
wanted to throw herself around in a gym
and enjoy herself
she reached a high level but the culture
within the sport she loved
left her broken it was a massively i
guess love-hate relationship with the
sport i loved what i was doing but i
didn't like the way i was being treated
and it was a culture of fear and silence
i was so traumatized from what i now
know is dissociation i went home and sat
and stared at a wall and my parents
couldn't get me to talk about what had
happened
so i sat and stared at a brick wall for
six hours i used to stop drinking and
eating completely throughout the day
because i was fearful of them weighing
me because if we weren't doing well in
the gym that was obviously something
that was looked at hundreds of accounts
of physical and emotional abuse were
collected gymnasts were punished by
being made to stand on the beam for two
hours while others reported being
strapped to the bars for extended
periods of time
and then there was the tyranny of the
scales with young athletes dehydrating
themselves to keep their weight down
and it was coach led it's absolutely
child abuse i've seen comments online
people saying oh they're just not tough
enough they don't understand what it
takes to be an elite athlete it's
absolutely uncalled for as you can see
from the testimonials in this report
we're talking about serious physical in
40 of the cases in the white review
physical abuse emotional psychological
abuse that leads to serious trauma
eating disorders and ptsd
not victims survivors
the documentary athlete a prompted
american gymnastics to confront sexual
abuse it also led to gymnasts here to
call out the physical and emotional
abuse they have suffered
british gymnastics has now said sorry
that their failures enabled a culture
where abusive coaches simply got away
with it
we have to have the right coaches with
the right cultural attitudes to move
forward so if there are coaches that
don't have that then they must be
removed from our sport british
gymnastics has been
singled out here as a failing
organization one that's been insular and
focused on financial rewards rather than
the culture within the sport is it fit
for purpose
it needs huge reform and i'm here to
lead that reform and and i am committed
to doing that i will take all of the
recommendations from anne white's review
and i will look wider than that to make
sure that this sport is fit for purpose
going forward
saying sorry doesn't undo the damage
it's only meaningful change that will
validate the bravery it's taken to
finally call this out
tom parmenter sky news